il arrive 10 mn en avance. Sting et
ses 7 musiciens à l'heure pour le
coucher de soleil sur Chambord avec un
message pour le public chauffé à blanc
deux ans d'attente et autant de report la soirée
à tout d'une libération. à 70 ans l'anglais n'en
finit pas de faire rêver : " c'était magnifique
c'était super" - "c'est pas la 1e fois fois qu'on
le voit mais c'était magique avec le château
derrière" - "ah bah que du bonheur on était
contents on est bien, on va rentrer avec le
sourire" - "encore une fois le cadre fait que
c'est magique et puis le gars a 70 ans et il
est toujours sur scène" quelques heures avant
les portes ouvrent sur une foule qui n'a pas
le temps pour être au plus proche de la scène.
le chanteur lui découvre les lieux en début
d'après-midi pour les derniers ajustements avec
Patrick Roberts un ami et violoniste australien
invité pour l'occasion sur la chanson "Fragile".
Autre violon à se produire quelques heures
avant, le duo GRANDE jouant pour l'occasion
à 8 mains devant les vingt mille personnes
présentes. Sélectionné parmi des dizaines de
groupes locaux et validé par Sting lui-même, il
raconte une expérience presque comme les autres.
"Finalement le concert lui même on l'a
vécu comme n'importe quel autre concert
parce qu'on fait notre truc et on est devant
des gens et s'ils sont 10 ou ils sont 20 000,
on fait quand même notre truc... par contre
c'était surtout l'appréhension qui a été très
différente et le fait d'y penser pendant plusieurs
semaines..." Et les producteurs eux, pensent
déjà à demain et à une autre tête d'affiche,
prête à faire vibrer les pelouses de Chambord